the Joe Rogan experience immediately I
put up the post and I saw one negative
comment I'm like I'm reading this [ __ ]
one of the things that happened while I
was there was my phone [ __ ] up I
dropped my phone on the first day and
when I dropped my phone in the first day
it just went haywire wouldn't work
anymore
and so I had to get a new phone so I
ordered a new phone and had it shipped
to the island and when I was doing that
I didn't use anything I didn't use any
apps I didn't check my email I didn't
check Twitter and I felt better I felt
better he went cold turkey
I went cold turkey for three days yeah
and while I was out there going cold
turkey I was like I feel better like
this is better like checking all that
stuff all the time like do I need to
know about the Mueller probe 24/7 do I
know I need to I don't
what about stormy Daniels do I need to
know what the latest stormy Daniels
lawsuit is if I was a super billionaire
character I'd give stormy Daniels money
and go please stop no but everybody I
don't I don't want any hear it what do
you want money
you want money I'm not even saying that
he's not guilty that she's you know
she's in the wrong I don't think she is
but what are you looking for let's can
we get this out of the news I don't need
to hear this anymore he [ __ ] you I get
it yeah well how do people [ __ ] a lot
of people since that time you know it's
irritating what you pay $135,000 like
okay so you're gonna just keep it on the
DL right we're good 135 yeah get the
money now she's talking what kind of
deals that I don't think she has that
money anymore I think she spent it oh
she needs more money she needs more
money yeah and I think she realizes this
is an opportunity for you know I don't
know how to look at it because of one
hand I'm like well I think we should
hold the president up to higher
standards and you you shouldn't be able
to just lie all the time and be the
president because how could we trust you
if it comes to something serious like
war with China or something crazy or
invading Iran let's just go off the
charts they have craziness yeah I got to
be able to trust you with everything if
I can't trust you that you you don't
want to tell everybody that you banged a
porn star
yeah wouldn't be great if you just had
a press conference and ladies gentlemen
who cares yeah who cares yeah I I just
good I enjoy sex I'm a heterosexual man
in Melania yeah before he was elected or
whatever it was it's like I shouldn't
have [ __ ] this porn star but I
couldn't help myself
I'm a pig yeah but I'm doing a good job
as a president the economy is up yeah
unemployment's down thank you good night
support the troops hey but what there's
nothing so you say you can't trust him
because if you lie about this stuff yeah
but okay so you say another president
how do you know they're not lying they
are lying yeah so I mean I think they've
all lied I think look one of the things
that you know I had a conversation with
a friend of mine about a Hillary Clinton
and he's he's a big Hillary Clinton
supporter to the point where it's like
he like Jamie with the Cavaliers hat on
he might as well have a Hillary Clinton
hat on he's like a Hillary I'm sure they
do
I'm with her this guy is a him and his
wife are both like super Hillary
supporters and I'm like it doesn't
bother you at all that she deleted
30,000 emails it doesn't bother you at
all right like they told her there's a
probe we need to see all your emails
just deleted them all that doesn't
bother you like that doesn't seem like
maybe she's a liar and then when you
hear commis account of what happened
versus her account of what happened
she's clearly not being honest that
doesn't bother you and he's like well I
I think in comparison she doesn't align
as much I'm like what are you talking
about like these are lies it doesn't
matter in comparison right so my point
is I think anybody who gets to that
level of that business
yeah he's slimy right in one way or
another you're everyone's slimy maybe
but we would like you to not be yeah
it'd be great we'd like everybody did
not be yeah he I don't know I think the
only way to get to the bottom of it is
get him on the podcast I would love to
get him on the podcast I'd love to get
him drunk yes so does that Rick that's
oh that's what I was one so you know
most people have podcasts that aren't
the almost the Joe Rogan but that's
almost true right now most people do
have podcasts now I know okay I love you
fish so most people that do they'd be
like
got this get this dream guest list you
know the wish list and these are my I'd
love to have these people
I was thinking about you it's like it
seems like and I don't know I'm not you
but like the court need to Walter the
people you're interested in are more
important to you than say like the the
eilat the like it the president United
States I mean you know so what how do
you do you have a wish list of guests I
don't have a wish list no no no we were
talking about this on the plane ride I
don't I like talking to my friends yeah
I like talking to you yeah I like
talking to interesting people like the
sleep expert I had on the other day
Matthew Walker I don't like him or Pete
sleeps three hours a night so I didn't
like that so I'm gonna ignore him but
you said that that guy you Monday we
have Michael Chandler I'm looking
forward to that like I like talking to
interesting people yeah they don't have
to be famous to me at all right also my
favorite podcasts are people that aren't
famous at all
yeah just like people that are
interesting I mean that's obviously a
pretty blanket state right but I like
people that are doing things that are
unique people that are that are like
masters at a craft people that are
working hard people that inspire me I
like to be inspired you know I'm like I
like talking to people who are curious
and who've studied things you know
whether it's Sean Carroll or Neil
deGrasse Tyson or so people that
understand things that I don't
understand so I could pick their brain
and ask some questions about stuff that
to me is interesting but Trump haven't
sitting down with Trump would be to me
like a lot like sitting down with my
friend Alex Jones like it's be like okay
I would be like okay if you talk to him
for three hours yeah what kind of crazy
stuff would come out it'd be awesome I
really think that if he wasn't president
I would like him I would really I would
like him I would say I would think he's
a character if I didn't have business to
do with him where I was worried about
like you know getting screwed over and
some sort of a deal or something like
that yeah I would like him I think he's
a wild man he's a character yeah
he's a [ __ ] seven year old dude with
crazy [ __ ] hair he wears a red bat
baseball hat everywhere that says make
America great again on that's awesome
you can't even wear that hat in bars
could you imagine that he is so divisive
like he's so that people are so
conflicted one side of the other against
him that if you wear that hat they will
kick you out of places yeah what world
do we live in yeah well you can't wear
something that says make America great
again yeah how could that be considered
anything but positive house I don't
write it in but he's people hate him so
much and that's so that's to me even a
great accomplishment from what he's done
is like he's got so much hate and he
still look at all the positives as it
happened well most people don't think
any positives that happened because if
most people in my most people know I
think there has been well I think most
people live in an echo chamber yeah and
if you're like my friend who's a giant
Hillary Clinton supporter that all you
hear is trying the devil yeah and you
know he was like completely convinced
that it was going down and Trump's gonna
be kicked out of office in the first 60
days and he's like trust me it's not
gonna last a year I'm like it's not
gonna last a year yeah a year later he's
crying he's [ __ ] pulling his hair out
he's going crazy
[Applause]